hey you guys
time for another movie retrospective
it's raining outside you got some
pumpkin bread in the oven
yeah and we're talking about a [ __ ] up
serial killing movie from 1986
uh this is henry portrait of a serial
killer
starring michael rooker i saw it around
the time where it came out
it was shocking at the time it was not
so much nowadays but it's still like a
really good
disturbing kind of movie yeah it seemed
very realistic back in those days you
know what i mean because the way it was
edited
and it was shot on 16 millimeter yeah it
just it just looked
it looked like a look like a crime scene
[ __ ] yeah it definitely has this
video or something feel to it what's
funny about it is that you know we know
we know
the um we know this case that you know
about henry lee lucas we know it pretty
well we did a show on it
it's very fictionalized it's it's
nowhere near
the story is nowhere near what really
happened
um it's kind of it's kind of a decent
portrayal of what they were like but not
but what strikes you when you watch this
movie is how good-looking michael rooker
is
he was a good-looking dude but yeah he's
still a good-looking dude well of course
you know i mean he was quite young when
this movie was made
you know of course he's good looking
he's from alabama
alabama used to be part of mississippi
that doesn't follow no no yeah alabama
used to be part of mississippi it broke
off in the 1800s
but um no the the real henry lee lucas
was [ __ ]
man nasty same thing with otis they left
a lot out of the story
well like i said i think that even when
they were first
like um making this movie basically the
guy that wrote and directed it uh john
mcnaughton
he um just got interested in the henry
lucas case because he saw somebody on
2020
but he said i don't really i don't want
to make like a movie that's like about
him it's just like loosely based on him
so it's not you know so a lot of the
details you can't really compare yes
they did use a lot of um aspects of like
their real lives
and some characters but they changed a
lot too so don't like watch this
thinking it's like a biopic or anything
like that because it's nothing like that
it's just like a separate story
one of the things that they left out in
it in the movie
is that otis was gay and i would say
henry was bisexual yeah and uh
they had a thing going on and then they
had this 13 year old girl who was like
you know
way into henry but these dudes were
fugly though i mean they looked like
[ __ ] four
generations of [ __ ] half
interbreeding and stuff you know
just these dudes these dudes couldn't
[ __ ] function in
in society that was one of the reasons
why they went the way they went
and they lied a lot they were [ __ ]
par they were
um pathological liars uh they couldn't
have done everything that they said
killed 600 people
no yeah wouldn't they have had they
would have had to travel like 11 000
miles in one month
like in this shitty old car like for
them to have done all the murders that
they had henry probably what could be
classified as
as in real life he probably could be
classified as a serial killer i think he
killed enough
uh but the only thing that otis and
henry i think did together that they
know for sure is that
they robbed they robbed a gas station
and killed at least one guy there
and they did eventually kill that girl i
think henry eventually killed that girl
well what ended up happening and um the
thing about the movie too so in the
movie
uh henry lee lucas like lives with otis
where i guess they met in prison
which um that's not exactly what
happened they actually met in
jacksonville it wasn't in prison but um
and the
girl becky which her real name was freda
but in real life she did go by becky
um in the movie she's like old enough to
she's like you know 18 19 20 early 20s
something like that like old enough to
have a job and have a kid and stuff like
that in real life she was 12.
um and she was actually otis's niece in
the movie
she's his sister right but he's like
incestuous toward her
yeah you know but in reality it was a
niece yeah and she was way underage
yeah she was 12 when her and henry met
yeah and what's funny is that you know
the investigators knew when the
interview and all these people
actually she was like mentally superior
to henry
even though she wasn't the brightest
bulb either she had some mental
impairments
yeah they were all they were all [ __ ]
up but she was actually the smartest one
out of the butch
she wasn't the leader per se but i think
she manipulated him a lot
they said that she was dominant in the
relationship
with henry which is strange you know
what i mean but
when you see how kind of like mentally
[ __ ] up they were it
kind of made sense yeah these were not
um
quality yeah individuals henry was kind
of [ __ ] whipped i guess you could say
i mean and and the thing about it too
was that now the [ __ ] that they say in
the movie because there's like one scene
in the movie where henry and um
becky are like getting to know each
other and they did have like
a romance thing in the movie but like i
said in the movie she's much older than
she was in real life
and some other [ __ ] was different too
but he says about
um his dad his dad's getting his legs
cut off
like when he was younger which that did
happen like his dad i think is
although i think in the movie he said it
was a truck accident and i think that
in real life i think he got him cut off
like by a train or something like that
he fell didn't he fall asleep drunk on a
train track yeah something like that
sleeping on train track and the stuff
that he said in the movie about his mom
being uh a prostitute and like making
him watch dressing him in women's
clothing that is supposedly true also
so the stuff that he says to becky in
the movie about his background
um as far as they can determine that is
actually what his uh
what his family life and upbringing was
like so like i said
that's a serial killer genesis he was a
scientist a killer just
i don't think he either i'd be i'd be
surprised i'd be surprised if he killed
six people
i had to look up um because he was
eventually
convicted of 11 11 but
from what i've seen they don't know how
many people he killed they're pretty
sure
he killed three um he did kill his mom
although not outright like what ended up
happening was him and his mom had an
argument
and he said that the mom hit him over
the head with a broom handle
and then he said that oh i just like
smacked her across the neck except oops
i had a knife in my hand
like okay and like kind of slit her
throat but she didn't die right away
like somebody came home and found her
like called the ambulance and everything
but then she was dead by the time she
got there because she'd had a heart
attack like from shock
so he was actually um so the cut didn't
kill her blamed her yes so she was
actually blamed for that
um and there and they suspect that he
eventually ended up killing
becky and also this woman that they were
living with
like this old like him and becky like
got this job
looking after this old lady like she was
in her 80s or something and she was like
bedridden
and they like um henry got a job like
working
as a roofer or some [ __ ] and then becky
was supposed to take care of the old
lady
and they started like stealing from old
lady like writing out checks and like
forging her signature and [ __ ] like that
so um they think that probably henry
killed that old woman too
but those are pretty much the only three
that they're
completely certain of yeah it's been a
long time since i've looked at his case
but from what i remember
my reaction to the ones that he got
convicted for a lot of them
i remember it being really flimsy you
know what i mean the one people
confessed this to stuff but he confessed
to everything that he did yeah he would
confess to every [ __ ] thing
so just because he got convicted of it
didn't mean
yeah the one that he was convicted of i
think was uh the murder of orange socks
who they later identified i think her
name was deborah jackson
i wrote about her in my book actually
and um i'm not sure like how
solid the evidence was for that yeah um
he was
he got in prison for a lot of he did
like attempted kidnapping uh burglary
[ __ ] like that so he it wasn't just
murders um but for sure he did not do
like i said i've seen the lowest um
estimate i've seen is three
highest estimate i've seen like maybe 40
but most people are like even that's
a little this dude he didn't have the
traits he had
to have to be a real prolific serial
killer he just he just didn't
yeah he wasn't intelligent enough he
wasn't good-looking enough he couldn't
get people to trust him or get into a
car with him
you know what i mean you know
a serial killer has to get has to have
enough social
uh uh uh i guess charisma you know what
i mean to get
unless these prostitutes unless they
just kill prostitutes
if you look at those guys you're like oh
no thanks because they don't they don't
look like they had a dime
you know what i mean and you know what i
mean so they couldn't afford anything
you know
and just their faces and just how they
looked they were just
super super sketchy looking i i i didn't
yeah i mean when you see these two guys
together it's like if you saw them like
walking down the street towards you you
would like run screaming
yeah i mean like anybody would a ten
dollar crack [ __ ] would go nah
no thanks no i have stones
yeah so that said like so so don't watch
this movie thinking that it's like a
biopic or it's like anything
it uses some aspects of their crimes and
their and their backgrounds and their
life and stuff
but it's highly highly fictionalized and
even
like i said the director had said that
he wanted to make something like
fictional now what ended up happening
with this like i said this movie only
cost like 100 110 000
what happened was that the guy that made
it john mcnaughton
the director he was just i think this
was like his first major directoral
job at least of like a fictional movie
he had made a couple of documentaries
and there were these producers and they
really liked his documentaries that he
made so they're like okay well we got
this financing
um to make like you know another
documentary
and they were gonna make this one
documentary but all the [ __ ] fell
through like the people that they were
supposed to
like get the footage from were like uh
no now we want like twice the amount of
money like for that footage and they
were like yeah [ __ ] you
so they basically still had the funding
so they said to john mcnaughton who just
like was
he worked as like a delivery guy or
something like that like for their
business and he would they were like
well why don't you make a horror movie
you know what i mean because that's
those are usually like a pretty safe bet
so as i said john mcnaughton had seen
something about henry lucas on
2020 and said okay well i'll make a
movie about
a serial killer now as i said it seems
like
nowadays this is one of those movies
kind of like the texas chainsaw massacre
where if you saw it a long time ago
because i
we watched it last night and i had not
seen it for
a really long time and in fact i had
forgotten that it was so old it was
actually shot in 1985
and it was released sort of in 1986 like
to festivals and stuff but it had such a
hard time finding a distributor
that it didn't really like seep its way
into the public consciousness until like
the late 80s early 90s
like was when it was got more of a wider
release because it because there was a
bunch of [ __ ] with the mpaa they wanted
to give it an
x and then they were and then finally
like uh when they came about with that
nc-17
rating this was one of the movies that
kind of spurred the because they're like
well we need a rating that's
you know kids can't see it but it's not
a porno you know what i mean
so it was this movie i think it was um
tie me up tie me down was another one
and uh the cook the thief his wife and
her lover
i think those were kind of the three
that came out like right around the same
time that
spurred the uh creation of the ncaa it's
funny how
i perceived this movie back back in
those days and then i look at it now
it's not
tame but it's pretty tame by today's
standards sure
and that's what i was going to say it's
kind of like you know texas chainsaw
massacre where people remember it being
a lot
gorier than it really was then it really
is i'm not saying this movie isn't
disturbing
um i'm not more disturbing back then
though yeah
and i'm not saying that it's not well
done because it is it's very well done
it's well
acted but it's not a gore fest no you
know what i mean it's like even this
even the [ __ ] that's like disturbing
like i really like
if that's the right word to use i really
like the opening sequence of this
where they're basically showing henry
played by michael rooker
just kind of going about his life and
they kind of made him
sort of a nice dude like or not anyone
you'd suspect of being a serial killer
so he's just like going to a diner and
like you know leaving a tip and saying
oh you have a nice smile to the waitress
or whatever
and just being like really gentlemanly
and [ __ ] and then they intercut it
with just kind of like crime scene sort
or you know just just shots of like his
victims
and i like the way that the shots like
linger on just like these dead women
just like laying like face down
like in a [ __ ] thing with garbage
going past
like there's one of the really famous
one that got cut out of a lot of um
prints of it was the one with the
prostitute that he just killed and he
left her like on the toilet
like with her top all off and she had
like a bottle like stuffed into her
mouth i remember that one yeah yeah so
so they just kind of like linger on
these shots and then
you know juxtaposing it with him just
going about
a normal day like he's a normal dude and
there's something like really creepy and
like really effective about that i think
yeah you know what i mean i thought it
was a good movie the acting was good
the casting was good the tone the way it
was shot
it really took me back to michigan in
the late 80s
the rust belt area looked like that was
real shitty in a lot of places yeah
[ __ ] broken down shitty cars from
the 70s that were falling apart just
rusting like [ __ ] crazy
it just kind of took me back to to those
days of way things used to look
up in the rust belt it's [ __ ] you
know
bad i forgot it was almost look like
soviet almost like the soviet union yeah
it's like everything kind of looked like
crap crappy i'm not really sure i mean
because i think i mean obviously
um the real henry lee lucas and uh
otto's tool like kind of moved around a
lot
this one he kind of talks about that
like that's kind of his mo like you
can't use the same weapon all the time
you have to like keep moving around like
that's how he's not gotten caught for so
long
but the movie just basically
concentrates on
um him and otis and becky like being
in chicago yeah um and i guess they just
like
juxta they just put it there because
that's where john mcnaughton was from
and that's
so they was probably just cheaper to
film right so that's what i'm saying
today's just kind of like concentrated
on this one
the tone was really good the action was
good the practical special effects were
good i mean
you watch the movie you buy it and
especially the edit
but you know what i didn't notice i
didn't notice the first time that i saw
it and i noticed it at this time
was the score yeah really good almost
industrial skull
score it's almost almost like skinny
puppy insert yeah
almost like a skinny puppy song in
certain uh in certain scenes
um and you know hills have eyes had that
kind of an industrial kind of a
sound effect it's just not really music
but noises
this one was noises turned into music
kind of like kind of the way skinny
puppy
would do it and i liked it i like too
the way like i said when they did these
long shots of the victims like that are
just very slow
just kind of like slowly panning back
from like this horrible like
scene of this dead woman um and then
they would
over the soundtrack it would be like the
sound of the crime occurring but you're
not seeing the crime occur
you're just seeing the aftermath but
you're just hearing it and i thought
that was a really really good
um that was a really good technique it's
a really good art flick
yeah horror art flick about a serial
killer
kind of like in the way that hills have
eyes as a horror art flick
and so so was so was um
chainsaw massacre the first one was kind
of like a horror art flick it's
like that yeah and this kind of
definitely has that vibe like i said
because it was made for very cheaply
um it was made on 16 millimeter um there
is
also kind of a thing like you said
there's just kind of this gritty
it's because i made a joke while we were
watching it last night i was like oh
this is like low life's the movie you
know what i mean because it's like
everyone is
sketchy and gross and dirty and
everything and it's just like this
this underbelly of you know the seedy
underbelly of all these people like in
the city like
just being lowlifes and so there's
something like really
unsettling i think about seeing
henry as you know the main character
who is obviously a monster
but then it's almost kind of like he's
almost
normal you know what i mean like he can
go about his life and he's just like
doing regular [ __ ]
it's like you know him and otis are just
like yeah let's go get a beer let's go
to a bar or something like that and then
they just go to a parking lot and like
pick up some prostitutes and then like
break their necks
you know what i mean and it's not and
it's the way that they react to it it's
just kind of like not
that big a deal and i think that's kind
of what makes this creepier is that it's
just part of their everyday life and
they don't really see
yeah watching this one i could really
see how this movie
influenced natural-born killers did you
notice that oh yeah yeah yeah big time
what really stands out though for me
this movie
this this movie is a michael rooker
movie he [ __ ] sells this role
his acting is very good like i said
before i forgot how good looking he was
yeah he still is good looking you know i
loved him in [ __ ] as merle yeah dixon
just a super believable character he's
real tough looking in this
he's in good shape he's got curly hair
and he's
kind of [ __ ] scuzzy and creepy and uh
merle is more intense more intense more
verbal version of this you know what i
mean
more normal i would say uh merle is more
kind of like a [ __ ]
mississippi hardcore backwoods clan type
guy
you know um and
and he i think he's a great actor you
know i've seen a lot of his movies he
was in that one was called squirm
remember was it called no one's called
squirrel no he wasn't it was the one
with the aliens where they would
impregnate you
and you turn into a big uh oh right
right right
uh slither slither that's what it was
and those little worms he was in that it
was really good i think he was in
guardians of the galaxy too if i'm right
maybe he was remembering i haven't seen
all of his movies but i like him as an
actor he's real good
whenever he does a um interviews
he he he lets you know that he's a
friendly guy that this is not who he
is because [ __ ] man [ __ ] he comes off
as being [ __ ] real mean
yeah or or sketchy as you know he's just
a really good that's not how he is
though he's
he's he's a real funny nice guy i kind
of feel like that happens a lot i feel
like
people that like actors that kind of get
into a thing of like playing a lot of
villains or playing a lot of scuzz balls
yeah but usually if you meet them in
person they're like the nicest person
ever maybe they're doing that to like
overcompensate or maybe they get like
all their evil [ __ ] out like in the role
yeah and so then they can just be like a
nice normal person the rest of the time
instead of being a douche i don't really
goes the same but that guy from hills
have eyes and uh weird science yeah
michael berryman
yeah super nice guy weird looking yeah
it's just a medical condition you know
what i mean he's a real friendly
intelligent guy you know
yeah i've heard like the same [ __ ] about
like you know evidently women love him
like robert england and people like that
who
who kind of made their careers like
playing serial killers or monsters or
something like that they're usually like
super nice in real life
yeah um but yeah so so the thing about
this too that i thought was really
interesting
is that they made the like i said they
made the decision to make henry
more likeable and more sympathetic than
i'm sure he was in real life i don't
know i never bet the dude but i'm just
assuming um and you almost
even though you know he's a serial
killer you almost
feel sorry for him because he almost
seems like i think that's interesting
the way they set up the dynamic
between him and becky and they had it be
a little bit more normal than real life
because like i said in real life she was
way underage so there was like nothing
redeemable about that [ __ ]
um but so she's like a normal age and
she's like into him and like pursues him
because she thinks he's really
interesting
and he's very gentlemanly toward her
because otis who in the movie is her
brother
is like super creepy like always talking
about like her being a stripper and it's
like hey
change your shirt and hey and then like
near the end of the movie spoiler alert
uh henry comes home and finds otis
raping
his sister yeah and trying to kill her
and trying to kill her like strangler
and stuff and so that's kind of what
causes like this big [ __ ] rift
and again in the movie he kills otis
yeah which
obviously didn't happen in real life um
and also now he does kill becky also in
the movie
but uh which did happen in real life
that
you know but they he left it different
though it's like i think
he just buried he killed her and the old
lady at the same time and i think he
like just buried them together
i think i think becky was 12 when he
when when she
met when she met henry henry they were
they were 15. she was 15
later like when they yeah when all this
[ __ ] started i think she's like 14 15.
but like i said when the fbi and the
police were doing all the investigations
mentally she was older than he than than
henry was henry was
mentally both of them and so was oddis
otis was just
odysseus could probably be you know
described as mentally incompetent
yeah and um henry was way
below average in mental development uh
i just i remember what the what the age
what the investigators were just saying
that you know
becky was kind of playing on both of
those guys kind of egging them on
to do [ __ ] too she was getting a big
charge out of it made her feel important
um i think i think
i think henry possibly killed her
because she was gonna either leave
or tell on him or something like that
there was some kind of falling out
and she knew too much about him so he
killed her yeah because i think they
were doing i think they were defrauding
that old lady that they were working for
like on their like and i'm not saying
i i'm not like blaming the victim or
anything like that because she was just
a kid
but and she probably had a super [ __ ]
up life too yeah these people we're
talking about like 65
70 iq people these were they're dumb
dumb real dumb
yeah and so i think it's i you know it's
like i really really
i had forgotten because even like we
were talking about before with texas
chainsaw massacre
i had forgotten how not i remembered the
scene with um
you know the woman with the bottle in
her mouth i remembered the scene where
he was cutting otis head off like and
that he was dismembering
you know the tub and then putting the
head in the bag or whatever um and i
remembered like the very famous scene
where they filmed themselves like
killing a whole family
and then they went up and then they were
just like sitting there on the couch
like a couple of bros just like watching
it over and over
you know what i mean and be like i want
to watch it again like it was so
matter-of-fact
i think that that was what really
disturbed people about this film is that
just how
normalized it was like for them it was
just like part of their [ __ ] day
you know what i mean that's kind of the
way it was for uh those guys that were
running that damn torture
chamber up there right what was this
name [ __ ] uh
uh there's a chinese guy in the america
yeah that's who i was just thinking
charles ming
and um lake lake yeah yeah they were
kind of you know
about that i kind of think that case may
have inspired some of the stuff
in in this yeah that that because they
videotape stuff
and watch it yeah henry henry lee and
and honest they didn't videotape
anything
yeah i don't think they could have
figured out how a video camera could be
leonard lake and charles
were they did all everything they could
to get their hands on audio visual
equipment it was real expensive back
then
yeah because they wanted to videotape
everything that they were doing they did
videotape it yeah i've seen
parts of little yeah i'm not gonna sit
there and watch the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's it's out there but probably
probably real hard to find but used to
be on youtube you could find
a few seconds of here and there stuff
that there it was most of them talking
to their captives
wasn't anything you know graphic
but it didn't even look real you know
well that's the real stuff didn't even
look real
because you're so used to like of not
seeing it like
most people can go their whole entire
life like that it looked like it looked
like people doing live action role play
yeah it didn't it didn't it looked like
it was uh fake
you know to me yeah i can see the whole
thing you know they eventually kill them
in there
yeah yeah and that's not fake but yeah
it was real
yeah but it it looked like they were all
just playing along
and i think the girls were just playing
along because they they i don't think
they knew what was gonna happen
well yeah you wouldn't i mean right i
you know i can't imagine being in that
situation it's like what the [ __ ] how
are you gonna react it's like maybe
you're just trying to like
just trying to make it through the next
few minutes and you're just trying to
like placate them maybe because you
think maybe they'll like let you go or
maybe they're just like [ __ ] around
or something like that and basically you
know you don't really believe you're
gonna get like [ __ ] in the clutches
of a serial killer right how often does
that [ __ ] happen
so it's like um but yeah so that's
that's kind of
an astute observation that maybe they
they did use like an eng for
i think the thing for that because like
like you said henry henry lee lucas and
uh
otis tool did not videotape anything
there's also another very famous scene
in this too where they actually go
um because otis gets pissed off and like
kicks in their tv like a dumb ass
and then they have to go to some fence
or something like that to like to get a
new tv yeah stolen one
a solo one like that has this warehouse
and it's like all they have is 50 bucks
and he's like they're trying to give him
this little dinky like black and white
tv
yeah and then he gets like all pissed
off because they're like no we wanted
something
that was in color and he's like no i'm
not giving him you're fighting this big
[ __ ] fight
and then henry just gets pissed off and
like feet well he goes after him like a
soldering iron first like he sticks in
his hand right
and then like and then just as the kind
of coup de grasse he just kind of has to
like have the tv and he
smashes it on the fat guy's head and
then he's like tells otis to plug it in
like electrocutes it's kind of funny
which was almost kind of funny but kind
of [ __ ] up
at the same time that scene kind of
reminded me something out of natural
born killers now because it's kind of
some of the some of the homicides are
funny in natural born yeah that's kind
of reminded me
it's funny but it's like it's not not
really but really
but yeah it's funny so they want you the
audience to also think it was funny
kind of like what it felt like for them
is what was what you know
yeah i think that's kind of what but
yeah so it's it's interesting
to go back and see this movie again
because like i said i probably saw this
in maybe 1990 1991 because like i said
it came out in 86
technically even though it was made in
85 and um it didn't really get like a
wide release until
1990 i don't think this is something you
usually got on you rented it on feature
yeah i think i saw it on vhs or on hbo
or something like that and i think it
was 91 because i think i was either i
think i was just out of high school
or maybe i was still in high school i
don't know but so it was 90 or 91 that i
saw it
and it was a movie that like everybody
was talking about it's like oh my god
this is so [ __ ] up you have to see it
and everything like that but
you know seeing it now like now that i'm
old and jaded and i've seen
you know everybody nowadays has seen
everyone we had the whole torture porn
thing we had the whole new french
extremity thing we had the whole
where everybody has seen the most [ __ ]
up [ __ ] imaginable in movies
so this will probably seem very tame by
the comparison
yeah it doesn't stand out for the same
reasons
today as it stood out as it did back
then sure today
you would see it as a pretty cool art
film yeah serial killer
you wouldn't see it as real overly
horrible or anything
even though horrible [ __ ] happens in it
you've seen worse than that in some of
these other movies
yeah because they don't it's it's very
small it's much worse yeah well in like
a hostel anything like that
is human centipede much worse yeah yeah
and like i said some of those french
movies is just like okay so you don't
want to see that kind of they do
way more [ __ ] up [ __ ] than we do but
it's like um
so so i don't think that would be
necessarily the reason
to watch it i think that you watch it
for the acting
yeah the story and just kind of to give
you the vibe of what
the way things were back then it really
did take me back the tone is [ __ ]
great it's
it's it is it's really a time capsule
it really does take you back in time a
certain time anyways
it's kind of a creepy cheap feeling when
you're watching it because yeah it's
very snuff filming
and it i remember and it i remember it
looking even
having even a greater cheap impact on me
watching it on those old crt televisions
that they used to have and lower
and lower resolution it was it was even
nastier looking yeah you know what i
mean
cheap feeling yeah and it's supposed to
they're trying to let you know this is
happening in a real low rent district
yeah and it really does have that whole
kind of stench about
it yeah this reminds me a little bit too
[ __ ] up furniture
[ __ ] up wallpaper yeah everybody's got
old [ __ ] up rusty cars
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] up wood paneling on
the walls and it's just the way really
cheap places looked in the 80s
everybody's just like sitting around in
their [ __ ] gross ass underwear and
like
with beer and yeah all those
old-fashioned bathrooms with the [ __ ]
porcelain tiles and all that [ __ ]
pictures and [ __ ] stuff from the [ __ ]
40s and the 50s that they put in there
it's all long gone now you know in most
places everything's renovated now
yeah but uh just cheap looking [ __ ] man
[ __ ] but i remember places looking
like yeah
they [ __ ] felt seedy they they did
you sitting up there watching [ __ ]
salad jesse raphael or [ __ ]
whatever the hell it was he was watching
[ __ ] going on back in time
geraldo but yeah
so so i think that the impact that this
i think this was one of those movies
that had a lot of impact like later on
just for being and interestingly a lot
of critics like really dug this maybe
like when it came out i mean even
roger ebert famously like thought this
was a [ __ ] brilliant film
yeah it is and uh yeah and and i agree i
think it is our film yeah
because he was saying it's not because
it's showing
you know because roger ebert didn't
really like slasher movies because he
was saying well
the the you know the violence is too
glamorized or something like that he's
like this does not do that this actually
shows
what it would really be like to hang out
with these [ __ ] lowlifes that are
just going around killing people
just like it was a normal part of their
day and that makes it a lot more
disturbing and
you know by extension may be a lot more
responsible because you're
showing the [ __ ] the way it really is
you know what i'm saying so
so i can kind of get that um i heard
that they made a sequel to this
um michael rooker was not in it he
didn't return
but i've heard that it's not too bad so
if
you know it wasn't like super exploited
or anything it was kind of like the
continuing
uh you know adventures of henry in his
serial killing career or whatever
um i've heard it wasn't uh too bad
another thing i've heard too is that
i guess i was watching sinister reviews
who's this other guy like on youtube
that reviews a lot of horror movies and
he was i was watching his review of this
and he said that he watched he started
watching on amazon prime
and he's like it's all [ __ ] up on
there like the audio sounds terrible
it's like and everything but we watched
it on shutter it's on shutter
and it looks well it looks as good as
it's supposed to look which it's
supposed to look like super scuzzy and
like low rent and everything
um and the audio is perfect so if you're
going to watch it watch it on shutter
and not on
uh amazon prime i'm just like giving you
that little pro tip right there
also wanted to point out too that john
mcnaughton the guy that directed this
didn't look like he did like a lot of
work after although
he did direct that movie wild things
with nev campbell for the late 90s
remember that movie you'd probably
remember if you saw it i'm sure you
probably thought
and um i thought things like the kids
books no no
no it was like a it was like a sex crime
thing
what the [ __ ] was it even about i don't
remember what it was about i remember
seeing it but
because it had kind of all the 90s you
know
it people in it you know what i mean i
don't remember it um
you know i think what's her [ __ ] name
denise richards or
whatever that chick's name is she was in
it too i think um
and also he directed one episode of
masters
of horror unfortunately it wasn't one of
the good ones it was actually heckle's
tale which was based on a clive barker
story
um but not one of my favorite episodes
on the masters of horror are all on
didn't you watch them the other day yeah
i saw them on are they on tubie
yeah are they actually no they were i
think they were
they were on my xbox somehow oh okay
you know i had to buy them though oh you
rented them
yeah yeah one episode it's only like a
dollar because i think some of them were
on 2b maybe just one season
yeah i don't remember but i remember
watching i rented a brand new they
wanted that screw fry
solutions oh yeah yeah i think it was a
dollar yeah
oh okay so you could just get one
because they're only like an hour long
yeah
but yeah so if you have shutter and you
have not seen henry portrait of a serial
killer like i said don't expect is
gorefest but it is like a pretty
disturbing
um movie particularly for the time it's
cool yeah it's it's a really really good
film michael
rooker is great in it like all the
acting is great in it like everyone is
super creepy and scuzzy and it will make
you want to take a shower yeah this one
doesn't put rooker on the map it really
did i think this was i don't know if
this was his first role but it's for
sure one of his i'd forgotten how young
he was because like i said for some
reason i thought this movie was
he had a tough looking face yeah and
curly hair
and stuff and he was but he
it's just funny you don't you know i
didn't remember him as being a good
looking guy
it's because the movie at the time
[ __ ] just scared me but i think i
think this actually kind of type cast
him towards villain roles
he's so good at them though he's real
good at him
he didn't have to be i mean he also
could have gone along the lines to say
like um
oh die hard you know with [ __ ] bruce
he could have been a bruce willis kind
of guy
too oh yeah i would have liked to see
that actually
yeah yeah he could have done some heroic
stuff too it was just
he was just so good at this is that this
is the direction he went and i and i
think
merle you know him that the merle dixon
roll
[ __ ] you know what i mean that that
was like the magnum opus right there
well yeah that's
a heart attack pearl he was something
else
well that's the well i will say i'm not
an actor but uh from
what i know of actors they always say
that playing bad guys is way more
interesting than playing sure
well because there's so much more like
you can [ __ ] do with it that was
that was one of my one of the best
characters on the [ __ ] early walking
dead
yeah one of the best characters right
there yeah it was very believable
i think it was every bit as good as good
as um
daryl yeah and they were very different
one was good and one was bad but they
were both super interesting characters i
like them both
yeah i did as well uh yeah so anyway if
you have shutter
uh check out henry portrait of a serial
killer for your disturbing
not a fun watch but it's a really good
movie and i
would definitely recommend it for horror
fans and that'll do it for this
movie retrospective we'll see you on the
next one bye
you